We last week talked about the issue of women and early Christianity and I
obviously didn't address all the different texts in early Christianity that are
relevant for your discussion last week on women.
Uh,
but we concentrated on the pastoral epistles first and second Timothy and Titus
as representing one kind of early Christian way of handling women in their early
communities and then we talked to the x,
talked about the acts of Paul and Thecla as a very different kind of way to do
that.
We're going to shift gears for this week,
this week we'll also have something of a theme about it and the theme this week
is the interpretation of scripture.
How do you interpret texts?
So I'm going to change gear from what could be the basic method I've been using
in the class all along,
which is the historical critical method,
which I've talked about sometimes.
Explain to what that is.
We're going to talk about is that the only way for Christians to interpret
scripture today?
I get into that by talking about the letter to the Hebrews as one very good
example from the first period of Christianity of the interpreter of
interpretation of scripture themselves.
This is how Christians themselves interpreted,
interpreted their scripture and the ancient world.
So Hebrews,
this will be a lecture on Hebrews to kind of talk about the content of the
letter of the Hebrews,
but the main,
it's also used to shift our gears away from a purely historical critical
analysis of scripture and show how ancient people did it themselves.
And then the next class period on Wednesday I want you,
uh,
we'll talk about medieval exit,
Jesus,
late ancient and medieval exit Jesus interpretations of the Bible.
Now I got the feeling last week when I was lecturing about the acts of Paul and
Thecla that there are quite a few of you in attendance who perhaps had not
printed out and actually read the acts of Paul and Thecla.
I had a few blank faces and blank eyes when I was bringing up things from that
text.
So I know it's going to take work for you actually to download then reading for
Wednesday cause it's not your Bible.
Uh,
download it.
I would actually prefer that if you don't carry your computer around and can
read the text because I want you to look at the Teks as we're talking about it
on Wednesday.
Just like I want you to look at Hebrews today,
but printed out if you need to and bring it to class because I will be talking
about that.
And this is also your reading for Wednesday is not part of the Bible.
It's from a very,
very,
very important book.
One chapter,
uh,
which you probably should all rush right out and buy.
It's so brilliant and so wonderfully written.
Uh,
I published the book last summer.
It's called pedagogy of the Bible.
And let me just,
I'll set that a little bit of context.
What that is is I actually went around and studied 10 different seminaries and
divinity schools around the country,
all Protestant seminaries,
but very different.
Some of them were very conservative with conservative denominations and
churches.
Some were very liberal and progressive.
And what I did was I interviewed both professors about 50 professors and about
50 students,
most of whom were planning to be ordained into the Ministry of some sort.
So most of these students are people who are studying theology and scripture
precisely because they are.
We'll end up preaching about this and working in churches for most and most of
their cases,
and I asked them,
how do you,
how are you taught to study the Bible?
And I reported that material back in the first chapter of that book,
pedagogy of the Bible.
I basically just said,
well,
here's what I found and I of the main thing I found was that almost all these
people,
although they were really being taught,
they were supposed to be taught how to read this text as a theological document
for modern Christians.
They actually are pretty much only being taught historical criticism,
what the text meant in the ancient world,
just like I'm teaching you in this class now.
I think that just makes perfect sense for me to use the historical critical
method to teach you because this is a secular environment.
I don't assume that you're a Christian.
I don't assume that you're religious at all.
I don't assume that you're coming into this class with the interest of studying
the new testament as a document for your faith.
For some of you,
that's clearly the case,
but that's not the structure of this course,
as I explained from the very beginning of the semester.
So I use the historical method as the way to introduce you to this material
simply because it's an easy way to introduce modern students to a historical
document as we approach it that way.
But I've also said several times in the class,
that's not the only way to read these texts.
And so what we're going to talk about this week is water,
other ways to read these texts.
That's what I did in that book.
Then the second chapter of that book was a introducing theories of
interpretation,
some of which I'll do today,
textual theory,
uh,
and interpretation theory.
The third chapter of the book was I think that third chapter was pre modern
interpretation of scripture,
which is the chapter that I'm asking you to read.
And that's where I take certain key figures among the church fathers such as
origin Augustan,
the vulnerable beat,
the venerable be bead,
hard to say in England,
uh,
Bernard of Clairvaux in the Middle Ages and Thomas Aquinas.
And I show how those people read the Bible before the invention of the modern
method of historical criticism.
And I don't just do that because I think it's interesting I'm putting it in that
book because I'm trying to advocate in that book how schools should change their
curriculum,
how Christian theological schools should change their curriculum.
So they were better teach people who are going to be ministers,
how to interpret scripture theologically and not just historically.
So the third chapter is his pre modern stuff.
The Fourth Chapter of that book would,
you won't read unless you rush right out and order it from amazon.com and read
it on your own time is on theological interpretation.
What does it mean to talk about a theological interpretation of a text?
This is not the same as historical interpretation.
I explained that,
I have examples of it and then the last chapter of the book of Fifth Chapter is
when I lay out what I would propose as a new for theological education and what
the role of scripture should be in that.
I talk about that precisely because I want you to know that when you're reading
that chapter for Wednesday,
and I do want you to read it ahead of time,
I'm not going to cover everything at the time,
so please read it ahead of time before you come to class on Wednesday.
I'll use examples from it.
You'll realize that that's part of a bigger project that I had,
which was to address the difference between historical interpretation and
theological interpretation.
So that's one of the things that the one,
the things I'm going to talk about today is some of this stuff also that you
would've gotten in chapter two of that book had I assigned it.
What does the text mean?
How do you ascertain what a text means?
We've talked about this a bit already in the course,
but we're going to concentrate on today when there are different and even
contradictory interpretations of the text,
whether it's the Bible,
the constitution of the United States,
state laws,
a contract in business.
When we have disputes about the interpretation of the text,
how do you settle those disputes to honest people,
both of goodwill,
both basically intelligence.
I'll just read the same text and think it means something different.
How do you adjudicate disputes about a text?
Meaning where does a text meaning lie?
Is it with what the author intended the text to mean?
Is it in somehow the literal words that how they will be read by an inch
educated,
intelligent native speaker,
uh,
is our,
our text aloud to have multiple meanings.
Uh,
w what kind of texts are interpreted in what manners?
All of these things are fall under the philosophical,
uh,
field of hermeneutics or hermeneutical theory,
which is just a fancy word,
meaning interpretation,
theory and especially the term hermeneutics in theological education means the
interpretation of the Bible and how that should be done.
So I talked about one time previously,
adoption is Christology.
Remember this?
And I said there were obviously some early Christians who believe,
not that Jesus had always been divine,
but at some point in his life,
he was adopted by God either at his birth or his baptism or his resurrection.
And in fact,
I cited Luke three 22 where according to Luke's version of the baptism of Jesus,
a voice comes from heaven,
and at least in some of the manuscripts says,
today I have been gotten.
You remember that?
And of course,
if that today is a quotation from Psalm from psalm 22 but the person quoting it
is implying that Jesus was adopted by God or forgotten by God at his baptism,
not at his birth or before.
Now,
if you disagreed with that interpretation,
and if you're a good Orthodox Christian,
you should disagree with that interpretation because that's not now Christian
Orthodoxy,
Orthodoxy in the way we think of it now.
It didn't exist,
of course,
in the first century,
in a fully defined way,
it took a few centuries to develop.
But at this time,
if you're an Orthodox Christian,
you're not supposed to,
that Jesus was simply adopted by God at his baptism.
So if someone came to you with that reading of that text in the gospel of Luke
arguing for an adoption as Christology,
how would you argue against that interpretation?
You might have argued,
for example,
by saying,
okay,
let's look at how this story is told in say,
the gospel of mark or in other places where that today I had gotten,
used,
not found,
and you'd say,
well,
we're supposed to use mark in order to interpret loop,
but the other pregnancy could just come back and say,
well,
mark didn't include it,
but that's not a denial of it.
And Luke obviously included for some other reason.
So,
and you could also say,
well,
that's probably not what Luke meant,
the author of Luke meant to say,
because Luke seems to have other passages in Luke and acts where it seems he's
accepting that Jesus was divine in some sense before his baptism,
maybe even at his birth because the angels announced and there's the worship of
Jesus that happens then.
So you might say,
well,
we have to look at other parts of Luke in order to interpret this verse and not
just take this first,
but they could just come right back and say,
well,
who says,
I mean,
this is the clearest key in Luke of wind.
Precisely a g is actually becomes a son of God,
is not contradicted by anything else in Luke.
So you should take this verse much more heavily than what you're wanting to take
it.
One of the ways,
I don't know if I mentioned this before,
is did I talk about how some ancient Christians pointed out that the dove
descends upon Jesus at his baptism in these texts,
right?
And the Greek word for dove is Patty Stada.
Did I talk about this already?
Okay.
I can't remember what I talked about in my different lectures on this and what I
don't.
Okay.
It's the Greek word for dove.
And that's in the text.
When the dove comes down to on Jesus's baptism and some of these creased
Christian exigence said,
well,
if you took all the Greek letters here,
you don't have Greek letters,
like Hebrew letters have numerical value,
right?
So if you give each of these letters,
it's numerical value and you add them all up,
n equals 801 that's proof.
It's right there in the text.
801 right?
You don't know what 801 is.
You don't know your neurology very well.
What if I told you that 801 also is the addition of Alpha because it's obviously
one and what do you think 800 would be?
I'm want to make a guess.
Omega Alpha Plus Omega is 801 and what do we know about Alpha Plus Omega?
That's the nature of God.
That's the numerical value of God and Christ at the end of the book of
revelation.
So they went to revelation.
The last part of revelation where God,
God at one point says it,
and Jesus has says,
I am the Alpha and the Omega,
ah,
Alpha Omega equals 801 petty Stada added together equals 801 that proves that
the fullness of God,
the Alpha and the Omega came upon Jesus in the form of this dove at his baptism,
numerical textual,
proof of their Christology.
It's right there in the text.
You could say,
but that's not what the text says,
but they can just say,
of course it says it's right there.
Add up the numbers.
You idiot.
You see how we would not accept that interpretation of this text,
right?
Because we don't practice that kind of textual interpretation most of the time.
That just sounds too foreign to us.
We just say,
that's not what the text means.
You're just playing with the text.
You're getting these numbers and just you can make numbers mean all kinds of
things.
Do you know they're actually a good many people in the modern world,
Christians in the modern world who still do this sort of thing.
You can buy a book called Theo Maddix that adds up all the numbers,
all the letters of the Bible in different ways and shows you how different
things in the Bible numerically refer to other kinds of prophecy events and all
this sort of thing,
so they're a chili religious people now who still practice this form of
interpretation.
How would you argue against that form of interpretation?
If you just want to say,
that's not what the text says,
there's nothing you could do that would basically prove to a person who believes
that,
that that's not what the text says.
You can't just go to mark and say,
but look,
let me read it to you.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
That's not what it says,
and they can just say,
no,
you just read it.
Of course it's what it says.
You just read it.
The numbers were there when you read them.
There's no way,
just appealing to a text itself can settle disputes about the meaning of a text
unless you and the other person doing the arguing.
Share the basic presuppositions about what counts as a good interpretation and
what doesn't count as a good interpretation.
You have to share assumptions about method of interpretation before you can even
come to an agreement about the meaning of the text.
And what that proves is that the text can't control its own meaning.
The meaning of the text is not contained there in the text is simply to be
passively seen by someone.
You have to interpret it and you have to learn the methods of interpretation
that are appropriate in your society for particular texts.
There's so the,
the fact though is the way ancient people interpreted texts as this example
shows is not the way I've been teaching you in this class to interpret texts.
So what we want to do is put our imaginations back what counted for early
Christians as a good interpretation of the text and see what methods they used
and stretch our imaginations a bit more.
It's not hard to do because the new testament writers themselves are repeatedly
interpreting scripture for themselves.
Now remember,
they're the new testament writers aren't interpreting the New Testament as
scripture because they are writing the New Testament.
The New Testament didn't exist yet as scripture,
so when we read a Gospel writer who has Jesus interpreting scripture,
the scripture he's interpreting is what Christians would call the Old Testament
or what Jews would call the Hebrew Bible.
For them it was just scripture,
Jewish scripture.
That was what that was all the scripture that existed for the earliest
Christians was Jewish scripture,
so when they're interpreting what we today might call the Old Testament,
they're not in terms of the New Testament,
but this is great because we have new testament writers who now occupy
descriptor for Christians interpreting other scripture that was scripted for
them as we can so we can see how they did it.
Look for example at some,
well,
I've already done that.
I'm not to do that.
Psalm 22 if you want to look at that.
Some point is the song that talks about Jesus's up the Nazi.
I said,
I did it myself.
It's not talking about Jesus.
Psalm 22 in its historical context is talking about King David or some heroic
figure who's suffering a righteous man who suffers,
but it talks about someone's hands and fear,
feet being pierced.
It talks about them dividing his garments and casting lot for his clothes.
It talks about a drinking vinegar and gall mixed together or wine.
It sounds like someone being crucified,
and sure enough,
early Christians interpreted that song as a prophetic psalm about the
crucifixion of Jesus.
And in fact,
when you see the crucifixion of Jesus,
the different things that happen in the gospel accounts of the crucifixion of
Jesus are echoing the things in that song because the later writers said,
well,
the song 22 must be talking about Jesus' crucifixion.
So we'll add details to the account to make it fit.
Psalm 22 but you also,
so in that case,
what you already got his Christian writers,
followers of Jesus,
very quickly taking a interpreting the text there holy texts to be not about the
historical Jewish king that the text originally referred to or that we as
historical critics would say,
historical critics would say no.
That psalm 22 was not about Jesus.
It's about some king.
And uh,
the ancient near eastern situation,
centuries before Jesus,
that's not the way the early Christians did it.
They said,
no,
it's gotta be about Jesus.
So they're already doing something that modern historical critics within a
reject.
In my lecture next time on medieval excuse,
I'm actually going to walk you through some of the basic presuppositions of
modern historical critical method that you've been learning in this class.
And I'm going to make it explicit what you've already been learning.
So you'll have the method clear in your head.
And I'm also going to talk about how did this method arise in the modern world
and why did it arise in a modern world.
So we'll talk about that a little bit later,
but let's just look at how new testament writers then interpret texts.
Look at mark 10.
This is when some pharisees come and they questioned Jesus about divorce.
Is that okay?
In his teaching for a man to divorce his wife?
Now,
of course,
notice it's already put in a patriarchal context cause it's not about how a wife
can divorce her husband or how both of them can go to one another.
We've art.
We're already in a patriarchal context because the question is phrased is,
is that all right for a man to divorce his wife
and look at 10 verse three he answered them.
What did Moses Command you?
Ah,
that's a good thing.
Let's just look at scripture.
Scripture will probably tell us where the divorce is allowed by gun.
They said,
Moses allowed a man to write a certificate of dismissal and to divorce her.
So Jesus says,
well,
there's your answer.
No,
that's not what Jesus says.
Right?
Jesus said to them,
because of your hardness of heart,
he wrote this commandment for you.
But from the beginning of creation,
God made them male and female.
Well,
that sounds like a quotation.
Where's that a quotation from?
I can't hear you.
Thank you.
I'm not asking these questions to hear myself talk.
I know there were torical questions.
Just answer them anyway.
Okay,
so that's one,
a quotation from genesis,
but then the next,
for this reason,
a man shall leave his father and mother and be joined to his wife.
That's also from say it genesis,
but are these two quotations from the same part of Genesis?
No,
they're from two chapter two separate chapters.
So notice what's going on here.
Jesus first says,
what did Moses write?
Which seems to think he's saying,
okay,
we'll just go to scripture and scriptural.
Tell us and it'll,
and it'll give us read scripture like a rule book and it'll tell us where the
divorce is allowed.
Then they quote back,
what is exactly the proper scripture they're quoting Deuteronomy.
Uh,
whereas Deuteronomy 24,
the 24th chapter of Deuteronomy in the law of Moses,
it says,
if a man wants to divorce his wife,
that's fine.
But what he says,
he has to give her a written certificate of divorce.
Send her away.
She's free to remarry somebody else.
But if she do is she is divorced from the second husband,
she can't go back and be a joined again to the first husband.
In other words,
the law is you can divorce your wife,
but once you divorced her and she ends up with another guy,
you can't take her back again.
So that was the ruling in the,
in the law of Moses,
they site a text that's actually about divorce.
Jesus doesn't accept that text.
And he basically,
his interpretation sets aside that law,
that rule by saying,
oh,
well that was a concession that Moses did for your hardness of heart.
That really wasn't God's will.
God's will on this is seen in a different text and I'll quote you that text.
But where in genesis one and two is divorced,
ever mentioned nowhere.
The genesis passage that Jesus quotes here is not about divorce.
It's about marriage.
And Genesis doesn't forbid divorce explicitly.
It just says,
you know,
men and women will get together and get married.
God made them male and female man to leave his wife and cleave.
It was mental.
He was a parents included to his wife.
There's nothing in genesis.
Jesus is basically breaking one of the major rules of textual interpretation of
hermeneutical theory.
That's not only around in the modern world,
but also was around even in the ancient world,
which is
interpret the obscure by reference to the clear.
In other words,
if you have a text that you're not clear about the interpretation of it,
it's okay in ancient interpretation theory to go to another text that might shed
light on that,
uh,
that cloudy text.
But if you've got a text,
it's clear.
Don't go looking for an Emr,
obscure text and try to illuminate the clear text with the obscure text that of
course this against common sense,
right?
But that's exactly what Jesus is doing here.
He feels that he has the liberty to basically set aside a clear teaching that
permits divorce and he goes and looks for two other texts that don't say
anything about divorce and he uses them to express God's will.
Of course,
what he has to do is add to the text.
He basically has to add to the genesis text that not only is this a teaching
about marriage,
but therefore it is implicitly therefore a teaching against divorce.
Whereas you and I might read that genesis text and not see anything about
divorcing it at all.
So what this shows is Jesus himself is presented as interpreting scripture in
ways that would be completely unacceptable in a modern context to most scholars
of the Bible who are going to say no,
you're breaking several rules about interpretation.
There's all kinds of things on this.
We remember when we talked about Galatians,
I read you Paul's interpretation of the Hagar and Sarah Story from Genesis.
Remember how the story goes?
Abraham's married to Sarah,
but she's not having any children.
She's barren.
At least that's in the ancient world.
It was always the women woman's fault.
It was the woman who was barren,
never the man in come ways of thinking.
Of course we no different than that now,
but they always presented as Sarah was barren.
So Abraham has a child with Hagar,
Sarah's slave.
Then Paul,
instead of taking Sarah as representing Judaism,
the Torah,
Moses,
the law,
and Jerusalem,
he makes Hagar represent the law,
the current Jewish people and Jerusalem,
Jerusalem of the Jews.
Paul also seemed,
feel free to perfectly free to turn this text of genesis,
which seems like simply a historical talk about how did Abraham start having his
descendants,
one through his wife and one through is a slave.
And he flips that around into being an allegory about gentiles and Jews and how
non Jews would be taken into Israel and at least some of Israel,
it would be rejected by God and that the law would be put aside.
So Paul also interpret scripture in what ways that seem to us not only very free
but actually rather bizarre in some ways if you're not used to seeing this in
ancient world.
So what we're going to,
let's look at Hebrews now.
Cause what Hebrews is is one extended sermon that is also an interpretation of
Jewish scripture.
But what's really odd is that Hebrews is a text that uses interpretation of
Jewish scripture to argue against the superiority of Jewish worship and
tradition.
Okay,
first thing,
what is Hebrews and what is it not?
I said from the very beginning of the semester it was called the epistle to the
Hebrews,
the epistle to the Jews.
And I said,
it's not really either.
It's not a,
it's not a letter.
In fact,
it even tells you in chapter 13 that it's a sermon of admonition.
It says a speech of encouragement.
He says in chapter 13 verse 22 so it's not a letter really.
It has a a letter closing attitude a bit,
but it's not really a letter.
It's a sermon and it even looks like it quite possibly could have been written
to be spoken out loud as a sermon.
It's also not by Paul.
Now.
It doesn't claim to be by Paul,
but some,
some Christians throughout the centuries have assumed it was by Paul and that's
why it's often,
it's included in the Canon after Paul's letters.
But notice how Hebrews is a long document and we've noticed that the order of
canonicity in Paul's letters in the New Testament is by length of book.
They didn't follow a chronological order.
They put Romans first because it's the longest.
And then the letters of Paul come in the Canon more or less with some exceptions
by length.
So you get to file Lehman as the last of the 13 letters of Paul.
And it's of course very short,
one little page.
But then you have Hebrews,
which is a big book.
Uh,
so what's clearly going on is that it sort of got connected up to the letters of
Paul in antiquity,
even though it doesn't claim to be by Paul.
And some people in antiquity thought it was by Paul.
In fact,
some people believe that's how it got into the Canon because it was kind of a
controversial letter in the ancient world.
Uh,
so some people didn't want it in the Canon.
Some people think it got into the Canon precise because some people claimed,
oh well it's really by Paul after all.
Who is who,
who wrote it though of Paul didn't,
there'd been guesses all over the place.
Some people say Luke wrote it,
cause it looks like a very,
it looks very good Greek.
For example,
there's some books in the new testament that are really lousy Greek.
The book of revelation is lousy Greek.
Yes sir.
Uh,
well sometimes people say it was Luke,
the physician who also was the author of Luke and acts and then also of Hebrews
or some people say it was whoever wrote Luke,
although we don't know who that was so that people have a proposed different
theories.
But since the pistol to the Hebrews does look like it's has some influence from
Pauline type theology,
which has led some people to say since Luke was a traveling companion of Paul,
even if the gospel of Luke was not by Luke,
maybe Luke who is more educated,
he's caught a physician in acts.
Maybe he was one who wrote it.
So there've been lots of theories.
Uh,
some people have said Apollo's cause remember Apollos is called a in acts,
someone who really has a really,
uh,
a good gift of speech.
He's a great rhetorician of policies depicted in acts as a great rhetorician.
Well this is good rhetoric.
So somebody said,
maybe this is by Apollos just doesn't have his name.
Some people said maybe it's by a Barnabas.
Remember it says it's,
it causes a speech of encouragement.
And we're told an acts that Barnabas,
his name was given to him because it means son of encouragement.
So as I'm gonna say,
maybe Barnabas wrote,
uh,
this and in some people it was asked last week whether a woman may have written
the acts of Paul and Thecla.
And I said,
probably not.
Since there is a second century author who says he knows who wrote it,
that's disputed.
But,
uh,
some people would've said,
Prisca may be the author of this letter.
So maybe a woman was actually written.
Maybe a woman has actually written one piece of our new tech summit after all.
But the problem with all these suggestions is that their absolute guesses.
We have no evidence at all,
neither from the letter itself,
uh,
nor from an ancient,
ancient world.
In fact,
the smartest exigent in the ancient world was a church father named origin.
And he said he gave some different guesses about who may have written it.
And then at the end he said,
God knows God knows who the author of Hebrews is.
And God's the only one apparently who knows who wrote Hebrews.
It is a word of encouragement though.
It's a sermon.
It uses Hellenistic Jewish style speech styles and rhetoric and Hellenistic
Jewish exegetical techniques.
In fact,
it's an example of a certain kind of Jewish Platonism or popular Platonism
because it contrasts the real and the apparent,
the eternal versus the temporal.
The spiritual is superior,
for example,
to the physical and the shadow.
So you got the,
the,
the spiritual is contracted with the shadow of things.
All these are dualisms that come up and sort of popular plate Ising rhetoric of
the time now.
So it's clearly,
that doesn't mean it's written by a Jew.
A,
it could,
could have been written by a gentile who just happens to be very well educated
in Jewish scripture and knows has picked up also this Jewish exegetical kind of
technique,
which is why he uses,
I should also say this exegetical technique I'm talking about was not special to
the Jews.
Greeks could read texts like this also.
So there were all kinds of attempts to read homer,
for example,
the Iliad or the Odyssey as allegories for physical science.
The different gods represented air or fire or other elements of the universe.
So by the first century when this was,
this speech was composed,
this way of interpreting texts was already well known to educate people more
broadly,
not just Jews,
but Jews use it also in reading scripture.
In fact,
the most famous was Phylo of Alexandria who lived a bit before the time of Paul.
Um,
while he was around the same time,
but he probably died before Paul died.
And phylo has lots and lots of texts in which he interprets the Jewish scripture
through these allegorical kinds of methods among other methods.
I've given you an outline to the letter of Hebrews.
So look at that and I'm going to walk you through it real quick because one of
the things you can tell immediately about this text is that it's very carefully
constructed.
If you're just reading through in one sitting,
you might not catch all this.
So I've made the outline and talk you through it.
First.
There's the introduction and the thesis.
The verse two verses me.
Get there first.
Okay.
More.
I wish I knew a new testament song so I would know exactly where to find
Hebrews.
Okay.
Long ago,
God spoke to our ancestors in many and various ways by the profits.
Okay?
So we know this is going to be about the message of God given through the Jewish
prophets.
But in these last days he has spoken to us by his son whom he appointed heir of
all things through him.
He also created the worlds.
So he's going to contrast what was said long ago through the profits with what
we,
followers of Jesus have learned through him.
So already this contrast of things is going on.
That's the,
the,
the thesis of the whole speech is the old and the new and the superiority of the
new over the old.
So the next section,
section two on your handout,
the introduction to the superiority of Jesus.
So the first part is one,
three through to 18 he shows that Jesus is superior to the angels.
To what?
Angel.
Did God ever say you are my son.
Oh,
I'll put the in [inaudible].
So he,
he takes quotations from the psalms that God is addressing to the Davidic King
in the psalms.
He takes those as being references to Jesus and he sows the G.
God never made these kinds of promises,
uh,
to angels.
Therefore,
Jesus appeared angels be He.
And from three one to four 13 Jesus is superior to Moses.
So he shows through quoting scripture again,
Jewish scripture that God says things to Jesus,
that he doesn't say to Moses and to Joshua,
of course,
Josh wears just the one who inherited Moses position.
So He's included in this superiority of Jesus to both Moses and Joshua.
And see from four 15 to five 10 gs is superior to the old high priesthood
Israelite high priesthood.
Then you've got,
I've put them in bold a dis.
I digression as kind of curses and the main outline,
and these are very important because these are very skillful digressions that
will foreshadow something that's going to come up later in the same sermon.
So this one he talks,
he talks a bit about Mel Kisa deck.
And so this little section after five 10 is foreshadowing what we'll see in
Roman numeral five down further on your handout.
So the foreshadowing of Melchizedek.
Then you have Roman number three,
which is a digression of that goes from five 11 to six 12 and there you get a
longer digression,
which is an invitation to hire doctrine.
He says,
you need to stop being babies.
You've been drinking milk,
I'm going to give you some meat.
So we're going to go on to higher things.
So that's a digression,
which the invitation.
Then there's another uh,
foreshadowing dimension of examples of faith at six 12 for shadows what will be
in section seven below when he gives a long list of examples of faith from the
Jewish scripture.
Then Roman number for the introduction to the second half of the sermon,
which is our assurances.
We can be assured as followers of Jesus that we have blah,
blah,
blah.
So six 13 to six 20 is the introduction to the second half of the sermon.
Then in section five,
Roman numeral five,
Jesus is compared to Mal Kisa deck.
I'll talk about that a little more detail in minute.
First,
a muck Hasidic is superior to Abraham and the Levitical priesthood in chapter
seven one through 14 then be Jesus is himself.
The new melk is a deck seven 15 through seven 28 Roman numeral six,
the reality compared to the shadow.
Now this is where you get this thing of the reality is always superior to the
shadow and he makes Jesus and the liturgy,
the service,
the worship that Jesus introduces,
superior to the shadow that is the previous Jewish high priesthood and
Tabernacle Liturgy.
So you have a comparison here between earthly and heavenly liturgies.
Then section seven,
this is called para nieces.
That Greek word just means ethical instruction.
I've introduced this where before when I was talking about James,
so this is the paramedical section of the sermon.
Therefore,
he says in chapter 10 19 you should do this.
So you have a,
an introduction to these things.
Be Do this in spite of sufferings.
See several examples of faith in chapter 11 chapter 11 is basically a list of
examples of faith and Jewish scripture.
D,
uh,
encouragement chapter chapter 12.
Then practical,
detailed para nieces and chapter 13 didn't finally a call to leave the camp
chapter 13 eight through 16 which I'll come back to in a minute.
And then in closing admonition and bid addiction,
now notice what you've got.
This is a very well structured,
well outlined speech and it even has hints of what's going to come later.
So you have four shadows of things and you have reminders of things that are
coming that have come about.
Yeah.
But the basic point of the letter then is the superiority of Jesus is led,
Tore Ghia.
This is from the Greek word.
This is where we get the English word liturgy and modern English.
It refers to worship services.
So the liturgy of a worship service is what you do.
Do you cross yourself?
Do you bow?
Do you kneel?
What prayers do you say?
What is your prayer book saying?
That sort of thing.
Those are all literally liturgy and English,
but it comes from the Greek word,
which meant a much had a much broader reference him in any kind of service.
So,
for example,
when a rich man gave a bunch of money to a town and they had a big sacrifice in
a parade,
in a festival that was called a liturgy,
electric [inaudible],
it was a service to the gods,
but it was also a service to the town.
So these were,
so this comes to mean a broader sense of,
of service,
our worship and all that sort of thing.
And that's the Greek word that's translated as service.
In fact,
the word lead tore gos the same word,
but with o s on the intimate means a servant.
And that's what he calls,
um,
uh,
angels in Hebrews one seven and one 14.
So angels are called servants.
They're using the same word.
And in most of Hebrews,
therefore I said is a comparison between two liturgies to let Torigian.
One is between that of the Moses and the Tabernacle,
as we see in the Hebrew Bible.
And the other is that if Jesus introduced by his priesthood,
and in fact what we,
we have another Greek word.
So you get all this good Greek,
you can use a cocktail parties and impress your friends.
And you know,
make,
get new jobs.
Okay.
You know that the Wall Street banks,
we be really impressed that,
you know,
some Greek words,
right?
The Greek word for comparison is sin.
Crysis as we get,
we don't have,
we have an English word.
Nope.
We don't have any where that comes from that do we?
Yeah.
Syncretic is not as different than synchronous.
So that's the,
it's,
it comes from the Greek word for judgment creases and we get crisis from him,
which means a judgment or some critical thing happening.
And w the Greek word for with,
so when you judge something with something else,
that's a comparison.
So synthesis is a rhetorical term used by ancient education to describe
precisely this kind of speech,
a comparison of one thing to another.
So if you were a high school boy,
you need to learn rhetorical styles,
you would been practice and how to give a synchronicity speech,
a speech of comparison.
Sort of like in high school you were taught to do a compare and contrast essay,
right?
So you're taught a form.
That's what Hebrews is,
is a speech in the synchronous form.
And these two things.
Now notice,
so what the means of demonstration in and look at eight seven,
Hebrews eight seven what is he?
He's going to prove to you that the hearers,
of course you're not gonna need a whole lot of proof because you're already in
this Christian community.
You wouldn't be listening to the sermon if you weren't already a believer.
So He's trying to convince you that what you've got in Jesus is superior to
anything that the Jews could give you.
When it comes to this liturgy,
electric [inaudible].
So eight seven he says,
how do you know what superior for?
If that first covenant had been faultless,
there would've been no need for.
Look for a second one.
And that's very interesting.
Basically he's saying because Christianity exists,
that proves it's superior to Judaism
because otherwise God wouldn't have brought it about.
So the very existence of the second liturgy,
he says the second service,
that is the service,
the initiated by Christ.
The very existence is used to prove for this writer that it's superior to what
it supplanting.
But the main way he proves though this point is proofs from scripture.
And so we're going to look at a few more of that all the way through here.
He's quoting texts that are from the Hebrew Bible.
He's actually quoting them from the Greek Bible.
He probably doesn't read Hebrew according them from Greek translations of of
Hebrew scripture.
But most of them don't talk about the temple.
You might be reading like when he talks about the high priesthood and the way
the temple of the way these structures was,
cause he even talks about the building.
He's not talking about the temple in Jerusalem.
He's talking about the tabernacle,
the big tent that is described in exodus because that's what the people of
Israel are using when they're going through the desert,
before they enter the promised land.
They've constructed according to mosaic instructions given to Moses by God
exactly how this big tent,
we'll look what,
what materials will have,
what decorations.
That'll have its structure in different compartments.
And that's what they were.
They believed God Yahweh was living in the camp with them as they wandered
through the desert.
So this writer reads the descriptions of the tabernacle given an exodus,
and he reads the descriptions of the priesthood,
what they're supposed to wear,
what's supposed to do,
sacrifices.
And he says the real meaning of all that stuff is not at all.
The ancient Israelites wandering around in the desert is talking about us.
It's not about us as the new house of God is the new Tabernacle of God is
talking about Christ priesthood as the new priesthood.
So everything in the exodus,
he just reads through the Lens of Christ himself.
Christ becomes this lens that all of ancient scripture then can be read through.
And so what God says to somebody and knows the author of scripture is not in
Hebrews Moses necessarily,
although he would believe Moses did ride it.
He takes the main author of scripture to be God or the Holy Spirit.
He said,
it's called,
um,
the
well,
and it can even,
you can even refer to Christ in 1126.
Christ can be the speaker in scripture.
So God or the Holy Spirit are Christ are the actual authors of this text,
even though it had human authors.
So this is one way where he's already showing a very different world from our
modern world.
He's not too concerned about what the human author thought or what the human
author intended.
He believes that God's the author of this text.
And so you can figure out God's mind from reading the text itself.
So the center God is the author of the text,
this in trouty of Christ as key for scriptural interpretation.
And it's from the very beginning.
He said it in the mirror and the thesis,
we've learned this now through the sun,
not through the profits,
just the profits.
Um,
so let's look at one particular passage and we'll talk about this briefly and
then I'm going to stop and if I need to come back to this with the beginning of
next lecture,
I will,
because there's a few other things I want to cover.
But look at Chapter Seven.
This is where he talks about this milk,
his index finger,
okay.
This king [inaudible] of Salem priest of the most high God met Abraham as he was
returning from defeating the kings and blessed him and to him,
Abraham apportioned one 10th of everything.
Okay,
so the basic story is referring back to the genesis account.
Abraham has gone off to liberate some of his kinsmen who had been kidnapped for
ransom.
And so Abraham raises a little army of his own.
He goes off,
he defeats these United kings and he gets his kinsmen.
He gets his slaves,
he gets all he liberates.
Everybody gets the booty,
the plunder of the war,
and he's traveling back home and he comes to this place called Salem,
which just happens to be Jerusalem.
You see,
of course Salem means peace,
Shalom.
But this writer's taking it that a deck is the king of Salem and connecting it
to Jerusalem.
Mel Milky.
And so he says,
so the story is Abraham then gives a tithe,
a 10th of the spoils of war to Melchizedek as an offering.
In other words,
Mel Abraham is recognizing Malkin Codec as being a priest of Yahweh,
and so he's good.
He gives a tithe of the,
as far as a war.
So to him,
Abraham apportioned one 10th of everything.
His name in the first plane means King of righteousness.
Melek means king and Hebrew.
SEDAC means righteousness.
Now,
as I said,
he's using Greek,
but he must have some kind of word key.
He knows enough Hebrew that he knows how to interpret this Hebrew word,
milky Melchizedek's to mean King of righteousness.
So he's taking the,
the name as having a hidden meaning.
Next,
he's called the king of Salem.
Well,
Shalom means peace.
So that means he's also the king of peace.
So he takes this again without father,
without mother,
without genealogy,
having neither beginning of days,
nor end of life.
So why does he say that?
Well,
no,
because it comes up in the text of genesis without us knowing anything else
about him.
You know how in genesis and the other parts of the Hebrew Bible,
it'll say so and so begat so and so begets so and so.
It tells you everybody's lineage.
It tells you who's everybody's father is,
even their names,
son of so and so is,
is a,
a reference to their father,
their and their,
their ancestors.
And he noticed mill kids that it just comes out of the text out of nowhere.
And so he takes that as a sign.
That milk is that it actually had no father or mother.
He sprang out.
I'll talk than us just all on his own.
He has no descendants because they're not mentioned in the text.
Well,
who else comes out with who else is the King of righteousness?
Who else is the king of peace?
Who else does not have a human father and a human mother in an informal way?
Who else has no genealogy?
Who else,
uh,
has no,
end of days or end of life?
Well,
Jesus,
so a deck is simply a foreshadowing.
He's a sign of Jesus.
See how great he is?
Even Abraham,
the patriarch gave him a 10th of the spoils and those descendants of Levi who
received the priestly office have a commandment in the law to collect ties from
the people that is from their kindred.
Though these are that there's enough from Abraham,
but this man who does not belong to their ancestry milk has a deck,
wasn't a Jew.
He's saying he was not part of that lineage of Abraham,
obviously collected ties from Abraham and blessed him who had received the
promise.
It is beyond dispute that the inferior is blessed by the superior and the one
case ties are received by those who are mortal and the other by one of whom it
just testified they lives.
One might even say that Levi himself,
that is the father of the Jewish priests who receive ties,
paid ties through Abraham for he was still in the loins of his ancestor when
[inaudible] met him.
Now let me explain what's going on here.
This one,
besides a little bit of ancient genetic theory,
a little biology,
okay.
According to ancient ideas,
inside the body of every man are not just little sperm swimming around,
but each of those little things is a hum.
Humunculus.
A little person
tiny
in the body of Abraham were millions,
teeny tiny bit.
I
say like Maddow,
Rachel Maddow on TV.
Don't.
I'm in love with Rachel Maddow.
I didn't know how to start sounding like her butt.
So the ancient gynecological theory was in the side of every man,
at least we're actually every one of his descendants would he would ever have
his sons,
his daughters,
his grandchildren,
his great grandchildren,
his great,
any of their descendants,
they all exist inside your inside the body.
So Abraham who carried within his own body,
all these tiny,
tiny,
tiny little Jews,
they would all come out eventually.
Now Levi,
who's the head high priest who then who?
The first priest,
all Levi's,
descendants at of Levi's body,
they were in Levi's body even when Levi's body was inside Abraham's body.
So even the Levi priests of the Jews,
we're all sacrificing to milk is a deck.
When Abraham was sacrificing to my kids a deck,
because they're all in Abraham's body.
When Abraham sacrifices to milk is a deck or gives his ties to milk is a deck.
Notice what this is.
The entire Jewish people,
all the Israelites,
whoever existed then and whoever exists,
we're all inside Abraham's body.
So they all ties to milk is a now Kiradech wasn't a Jew.
This prove.
And so then he says,
notice how mckissick also blesses Abraham.
Well,
if you're blessed by one,
you're not blessed by someone who's inferior to you.
You're blessed by the Bishop.
So when the bishop that proves the bishop superiority by blessing you in the
first place,
so that proves that no kids,
that it was superior to Abraham.
And then w when Abraham gave ties to Mick is a deck and Levi in body was there
for tithing to milk is the deck.
This proves that the Jewish priesthood itself recognizes the superiority of
milk,
his index priesthood.
Wonderful old proof from scripture.
Right?
Next time I'll start my lecture by finishing up the how the letter of Hebrews
ends book.
And then we'll set that aside as an example of ancient scriptural exegesis,
Jesus by Christians.
And then I want you to read the chapter online cause that we'll talk about then
later Christian x Jesus of scripture up until the medieval period.